is due to give birth soon between
worrying about when her family will eat
her home and lost cattle and no income
she doesn't sleep much
floods have washed away all our
belongings I'm pregnant I need to rest I
need to eat healthy food but where will
I find that there's hardly any help I'm
afraid I might die or lose my baby
before giving birth
she's one of 650 000 pregnant women in
flooded affected areas in Pakistan where
many of them are due to give birth in
the next few months Pakistan's
unprecedented Monsoon rains in July
forced millions of people to shelter and
makeshift camps where meals are far and
few between and with thousands of basic
medical and sanitation facilities shut
down mothers to be are struggling in
unsafe conditions with no access to
health care when the flood is there the
the whole water body become infected
there is no safe water then so now save
water lot of infections combined living
outside the houses these all make a
grave situation for for any country for
any area so if the women are already
anime they are having multiple
pregnancies they are vitamin D deficient
they are stunted they are wasted there
is high chance that they will be
affected very seriously flooding has
caused caused waterborne diseases to
spread fast pregnant women and children
are most at risk of facing lifelong
illnesses or even death Pakistan already
had one of the highest rates of infants
and maternity mortality rates in the
region before the flooding Aid agencies
warned that some of the long-term
concerns are an increase in unwanted
pregnancies and child marriages
Pakistan's government faces an economic
crisis and it's appealing for
international Aid to help those
especially in rural areas
authorities estimate it could take half
a year for the flood waters to fully
recede and with winter arriving soon
millions of pakistanis are facing an
uncertain few months ahead Sarah Al
Jazeera